At this year's San Diego Comic-Con, DC Universe
drew back the curtain on its animated Harley
Quinn series — a hard-R romp revolving around
the off-the-rails rule-breaker in the aftermath
of her break-up with the Joker — via the
reveal of a fresh trailer.
Harley Quinn, voiced by The Big Bang Theory's
Kaley Cuoco, endeavors to carve her own path
of chaos and crime in the streets of Gotham
without the shadow of her former flame looming
overhead.
To do so, she crosses paths with some major
DC Comics players, as well as a few New 52
pals, such as Sy Borgman, an elderly cyborg
voiced by Seinfeld's Jason Alexander.
Her ultimate goal?
Become a member of the supervillain alliance
known as the Legion of Doom.
With hammers swinging, money falling, drinks
clinking, punches and kicks flying, plus plenty
of expletives being tossed around, the Harley
Quinn trailer proves that anyone who tunes
into the series will see the up-and-coming
criminal Queenpin of Gotham City in a brand-new
way.
And, while they're at it, they'll get to catch
Harley taking down famed DC comics vigilantes
like Aquaman and, of course, Batman, voiced
by Diedrich Bader, returning to the role after
2008's Brave and the Bold animated series.
“That petulant primate’s poisonous plot
must be prevented!"
Harley Quinn features an impressive cast of
familiar voices, including Tony Hale as Doctor
Psycho, Christopher Meloni as Commissioner
James Gordon, and Wanda Sykes as The Queen
of Fables.
This isn't the first of Harley Quinn that
we've seen — a fourth-wall-breaking teaser
dropped during New York Comic-Con in October
of 2018, featuring a DC-fandom-dissing Poison
Ivy ...
"I think they're going to hate it, Harls.
They hate everything."
"No way!
It's got comedy, action, incredibly gratuitous
violence …"
By the looks of this new trailer, it seems
Harley Quinn will only get wilder as the first
season rolls out.
Lead voice actress Cuoco has teased that viewers
are in for an R-rated ride when the show premieres.
Posting the Harley Quinn trailer to her Instagram
page, Cuoco wrote,
"This show is gonna blow your minds!
Way [too] much fun!!! (and a tad R-rated)
#harleyquinn coming soon! [...] also the [Joker]
has an emoji but Harley doesn't!!?
She's gonna be pissed!"
The raunchy Harley Quinn animated series certainly
feels like a shock to the DC system, but it
actually comes after a few other legitimately
R-rated animated projects based on DC Comics
characters.
The 2017 feature Justice League Dark, based
on the comic of the same name, rocked the
R rating.
So too did 2018's Gotham by Gaslight, as well
as 2016's Batman: The Killing Joke.
The most recent R-rated animated flick to
come from Warner Bros. actually includes the
Cupid of Crime herself.
2018's Suicide Squad: Hell to Pay sees Amanda
Waller assembling a brand-new Task Force X
roster, with Harley Quinn and company hunting
down the coveted "Get Out of Hell Free" card.
So, while DC Universe's upcoming Harley Quinn
show is certainly going to drop some jaws
and widen some eyes, it follows a handful
of other adult-aimed animated flicks that
exist in the same comic book realm.
Perhaps reception to the new series will be
so strong that it motivates Warner Bros. Animation
to greenlight additional series in the same
vein as Harley Quinn — maybe even some focused
on groups like the Suicide Squad or the Birds
of Prey, both of which have had Harley on
board.
Only time will tell if the R-rated Harley
Quinn becomes DC's animated answer to Marvel's
Deadpool, or just a failed experiment in envelope-pushing.
"Harley?"
"It's me, d--khead!"
"Ahoy!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
DC characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.